it's not as if I'm out there trying to
just get anything I really really not
who I I don't I don't lie but more
importantly have you ever tried to find
a girl that I can be with be with and
have family with Ralph that's Josh
Duhamel talking to Dax Shepard on
Thursdays armchair expert podcasts the
46 year old says he's ready to settle
down again just over a year after
splitting from Fergie I'm not 30 years
old anymore 45 right I want to have more
kids okay
now yeah well in the next few few years
so it's more about finding someone young
enough to have kids Ferg and I haven't
had a great relationship I love that
girl I always will yeah unfortunately we
didn't work but I will always have her
back and she is the mother of my baby
Josh and Fergie calls it quits in
September 2017 they share five-year-old
son Axl Jack and make co-parenting a
priority he was with Josh shortly after
the breakup she had an amazing girl she
really is she's an amazing girl and I
think more importantly she's an amazing
mother yeah I have honestly sort of kept
my head in the sand throughout this
whole thing but she's an amazing mother
we are parenting our son as health as
healthy as we can so josh is looking for
love again he briefly dated 28 year old
actress I Sagan's Ollis this summer
around that same time though her he said
she wasn't looking summer break now that
the four is wrapping up what do you have
planned are you going on vacations are
you looking to date are you looking to
just have some more movie time or music
I'll tell you right now I'm play dating
with other parents that's what I'm doing
and just finishing the four and yeah
just being my kid being home and growing
or implanted
you
[Music]
[Applause]